So, I'm going to update the utility of s by looking at the utilities of
all the other states, including itself, as prime. And weight those based on my
probability of getting there given that I took an action. And what action am
I going to take? Well, I'm going to take
the one that maximizes my, expected utility.
>> So it's sort of like figuring out what to do in a state assuming that this
uhat really is the right answer for the future.
>> Right. Now why is that going to work? So
I just made up the uhats, right? They started
out as arbitary utilities. The next little step about
updating utilities based on neighbors makes some sense because effectively
is any state that you can reach. Which is
determined by the transition function. But, all I'm doing
is reaching states that are also made up of
arbitrary utilities so, arbitrary values. Why should that help me?
Well, it's because of this value right here. This
is actual truth. The actual word I get for entering
into a stage, is a true value. So, effectively
what's going to happen is I'm going to be propagating out the
true value, or true reward, the true immediate reward
that I get for entering into a state, say. Through
all of the states that I'm going to see and
propagating that information back and forth. Until ultimately I converge.
>> Still
not obvious why we should converge, because
we start off with an arbitrary function and
it seems like that could be really wrong. So we're like adding truth to wrong.
>> Yes but then, the next time
around I'm going to, I've been adding truth twice
to wrong, and then more truth to wrong, and more truth to wrong. And eventually,
I'm going to be adding, more and more and more and more and more and more
and more and more and more and more
truth, then it will overwhelm the original wrong.
>> And is that, does it help that the
wrong is being discounted?
>> Yes, it helps that the wrong is being discounted.
Does it help that the wrong is being discounted? I actually
don't know that matters. I'll have to think about that for
a moment. It certainly doesn't hurt. But I, I guess the
way that I think about this, I mean there's an
actual proof you can look it up but in the end
I think, I, I tend to think of this as a
kind of simple contraction proof that effectively at every step you
have to be moving towards the answer. Because you've added in more
of the reality, more of the truth. And if you remember the
utility of a state is just all of the rewards that you're
going to see. So, basically at every time step you have added the reward
that you're going to see, and then all of the rewards you're going to
see after that. And so you've gotten a better estimate of actually the
sequence of rewards you're likely to see from the state. And if
that gets better for any of the states, then eventually that betterness will
propagate out to all the other states that they can
reach or can reach them. That will keep happening and you'll
keep getting closer and closer and closer for the true
utility of the states until you eventually run out of closeness.
>> Cool.
>> Does that make sense at all?
>> Well does it also help that the gamma is less than one.
>> Yeah it does. the, the way I like to think of this
as, is as a sort of contraction proof, that makes, if you've heard
of those. So, the basic idea here is that you
start out with some noise, but at every step, you're
getting some truth, and that truth gets added, and then,
the next dideration, more truth gets added, and more truth
get, gets added. So, as you have some estimate of
some particular state S, you get to update it based
on truth. It's actual reward. And you bring in more
truth from the other utilities, as well. As this particular utility
gets better. That closeness to the true utility then
gets spread to all, from, to all the states
that can reach it. And because the gamma is
less than one. You basically get to overwhelm the past
in this case which is the original arbitrary utilities.
And so as you keep iterating through this, the latest
truth becomes more important than the past less truth.
And so you are always getting closer and closer and
closer to the truth until you eventually you do. At
least that's the intuition that I like to think of.
>> Yeah I, I kind of get that as an
intuition, though I'd probably be happier going through the math, but.
>> Well, we could do that, and by we, I
mean the students can do that by actually reading the proof.
>> All right.
>> Okay, so cool. So, this right here is a an easy way to find the true value
of states. And you do it by iterating and it kind of has a name.
>> It kind of has a name.
>> Yeah, what do you think the name could be?
>> Bellman. Bellman's algorithm.
>> No. No though that's probably reasonable.
>> Utility iteration.
>> Yes, except utility sounds better if you say value,
so it's value iteration. And it works. Remarkably well. So,
and it doesn't, doesn't give you the answer but it
gets you something that is closer and closer to the answer.
>> Right. And, eventually it will converge. You'll
get so close to converging it doesn't matter.
And, once you have the two utilities, if you recall. We
know how to define the optimal policy in terms of utilities. So,
if I give you the utilities, then the optimum policy is
just, well I'm in a state. Look at all the states I
might get to. Figure out the expectation that I'm going to get
for a given action. Pick whichever one is maximum and I'm done.
So solving for the utilities are the true value of a
state. Is effectively the same thing as solving for the optimal policy.
>> Hm.
>> Excellent.
>> That's cool.
>> I think so.